[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
we have now reached august which is
usually the final quiet month of the
year when it comes to video game
releases
but this time around there are a bunch
of titles out there to grab your
attention
and your hard-earned cash but i've also
found two free games to download this
month
one right away so if you're ready let's
do this
10 new games dropping in august 2020 hit
the music
probably the biggest game of the month
is actually a moderately priced
indie game with grand plans to take over
the world
this is four guys by the way if you're a
playstation plus subscriber you'll get
this one for free on the day
it's released august 4th fall guys is
also dropping on pc
but it won't be free over there i talked
about four guys a great deal in my
previous video so i'll be super quick
here
this one sees 60 players battle royale
style
whittled down to one person standing
using
up to five mini games on release there
will be 25 of those minigames
included but more will be added over
time the game will use a store to bring
in cash allowing players to buy skins
for their fall guy
and unlock emotes and colour schemes
using like a battle pass option which
i think is safe to say is the norm in
gaming these days but there will not be
any pay to win models here
if you're struggling to see the appeal
i'll link a full game to help you set
the scene
full guys is available on ps4 and pc
when it releases on august 4th
do you watch the fast and furious movies
well you may not know but a fast game is
dropping this month also
fast and furious crossroads an arcade
racer with gadgets and tech like a james
bond
film it's got a story starring the
characters from the films featuring both
their likenesses and most of the voices
too
the game puts dom and the crew into many
outrageous scenarios a cool thing we can
do is switch between drivers to get the
perfect vehicle in the perfect location
each vehicle has awesome tech to use
from nano shields to shock waves to emps
and even a harpoon the tech is the real
star of this game
so if you've ever wanted to roleplay as
vin diesel now is your chance
fast and furious crossroads drops on ps4
xbox and pc
on august 7th
speaking of driving games have you heard
the news about rocket league
the competitive juggernaut is going free
to play
out of interest do you already own it
the high octane football match
or soccer if you prefer has been ahead
of the game for almost five years now
and since the introduction of battle
passes into other free-to-play games
the devs have looked at that option and
believe now is the time to make the
switch
rocket league skill gap is a little
off-putting to new players
as going up against someone who knows
how to do all the mid-air ballet rocket
boosting can suck the life out of this
game but we've been assured the focus of
casual fun is returning with simplified
menus and refined customization of
vehicles
so here's the question when can we
expect it to go free
well we've been told this summer well
we're already in summer so it could drop
right now we just don't know
summer though officially ends on
september 22nd
so it's highly likely over august we'll
get to see this game go free
but if it's not remember it's only a few
more weeks into september
you can hold on that long right
how about a free game right now well if
you're on ps4 nintendo switch or pc via
steam
you can play fantasy strike right now
a street fighter inspired fighting game
with the usual ethos of easy to play
difficult to master thought process a
lot of time and effort has gone into the
net code for fantasy strike which
is of the utmost importance for online
fighters
the most recent update this week gives
us access to
all fighters including two brand new
characters named sirius quince
and general onimaru that's a good name i
like it
there is a subscription model in place
to get you to spend your money but you
don't need to because the free version
has
online casual ranked practice and versus
ai modes
unlocked right away and there's tons of
cosmetic items too
fantasy strike is free to download and
play right now on ps4 switch
and pc a huge game this month is ufc
4 one of the most visually stunning
games i've seen for a while
and with a new shockwave physics update
it lets you see the impact of your
strikes look at it
this is so brutal ufc 4 is a simulation
game which takes a great deal of time to
master to develop into an accomplished
fighter
intricate decision making becomes the
focal point if the previous games are
anything to go by
but just look at it it's beautiful the
likenesses the sweat dripping down
wow the clinch system has been updated
this time around as has the takedown
system and the submission system
so this should feel more like a new game
than any other sports titles do
you know because they're released every
year and it's just the same game but we
still buy them
i'm not judging also if you want to see
anthony joshua and tyson fury fighting
the octagon
it's possible with a pre-order bonus
and i gotta admit it i'm tempted to get
that ufc 4 releases on august 14th on
ps4 and xbox one
[Music]
have you ever played a wasteland game i
have to admit
i haven't but wasteland 3 looks mighty
impressive
imagine xcom mixed with fallout
and you get wasteland 3. set in
post-apocalyptic colorado we take
control of the last surviving member of
november team
a ranger squad the game is a turn-based
strategy title
in which we have time to plan our moves
just like a chessboard
but a single wrong move can see a
teammate annihilated
x-com gears tactics and now wasteland 3
these types of games are a great way to
learn about the law behind the game so
if you ever wanted to know what happens
if the fallout universe went in a
totally different direction
this is the game for you august 28th if
you're interested on ps4 xbox
and pc on august 27th surgeon simulator
is returning
but this time it's a little different if
you know the original you'll know we are
amateur surgeons
tasked with saving a patient with a
variety of ailments
that is still the premise but now we
have full control over our characters
and must solve puzzles in order to get
the body parts we need
to save that patient levels are
sprawling and exploration is key
which makes this a huge change from the
original moving a cabinet to find a
hidden path
is actually a regular thing to do all
the while we only control one hand
and arm which is deliberately hard to
function
the addition of the create mode is a
real winning element here as the
community will continue to create new
content
there is exclusivity attached to this as
this game will start out only on the
epic store on pc which means
us on ps4 and xbox we gotta wait a
little longer
exclusivity sucks but it's here to stay
here's a game with tons of potential
this
is windbound a zelda-inspired survival
game in which we manage our hunger and
slowly increase our skills to take on
the world's beasts
first of all it's another beautiful
looking game but in terms of game
mechanics it's the usual
break things to scavenge for materials
in order to slowly upgrade items to
progress further
the world is filled with fantasy
elements and secrets to discover
and once each area is ransacked we jump
aboard our boat
and find another island but here's the
best bit the world is procedurally
generated
meaning nothing is the same the game
semi-randomly throws down tiles of
landmass making each playthrough
completely different
you'll be given a unique world to
explore similar but not the same as
other players so does that float your
boat no pun intended what do you think
of wind bound
tempted to try it when bound releases on
ps4 pc xbox one switch
and even the stadia on august 28th
when you think of the greatest driving
sims ever made you're likely to go one
of two ways
either gran turismo or forza it's
difficult for another brand to make
headway
well project cars is trying once again
to break the glass ceiling with project
cars 3.
good title the key feature of this game
is racing in over 200 cars
which you buy using xp from racing these
cars can be customized both to look the
way you want them to
but also to be more performance ready
for each terrain or track you face
with all four seasons of the year
dynamically created and the usual
24-hour day night cycle
this racing experience is evolving with
new daily challenges and community
events too
could project cars 3 break out of the
shadow of forza and gran turismo
find out on august 28th on ps4 pc and
xbox one
[Music]
and finally have a look at scully a
platformer in which we can morph
into beings the core of this game is
rolling your head from place to place
collecting items and exploring areas
the best part are those moths in which
scully becomes like a goron like
creature
each one gives scully different skills
and breaks up the core rolling and
jumping gameplay
scully may not be made for the majority
of gamers out there but i do hope
it finds someone scully releases on
august 4th on ps4 pc
xbox and twitch so there we have it 10
new games of august 2020
and potentially three of them are free
to play i'd love to know your thoughts
but i know
nobody ever makes it this far if you did
please write
nintendo ds gang in the comments and
i'll try and find you
i'm adam from playstation grenade thank
you for your time i'll see you next time
[Music]